gone down to 28 22
he's lost four games and as we can see
as well liam leia scores better on
fighting chess so i think with the white
pieces he has a decent chance now to to
hit back in this quarter final fantastic
liam one of the players with the highest
fighting chess index score and that
means with the white pieces and he is
down by one point he will come out
fighting in this game what do you expect
david
i'm not sure exactly what opening to
expect but for sure liam loves his
fighting chess and he does
serve with both hands he plays different
types of openings he did a chessable
course uh last year i think on one d d4
as we see
the london system exactly and the london
system um he doesn't go for that this
time though we see the queen's gambit
and the gambit has been accepted
something we've rarely seen on the tour
actually but a very solid opening uh
from magnus carson and he's used this
with success so far in this tournament
in the air things masters magnus and uh
some quick moves there white is the
first to castle and now this last move
by white a bit of a strange one a bit of
a rare one just bringing the white
knight out in this uh in this manner
either way magnus maybe just going to
into solid mode now that he has a lead
in this mini match
what do you think guys good opening
choice from either side yeah yeah too
early to tell i know in this system
white can often uh exchange the queens
off but we've talked about the ending
and i think magnus will be very
comfortable if the queens come off the
board so this last move you mentioned is
peculiar but i'm hoping that white is
going to sacrifice pawn here by pushing
the other pawn in the middle up two
squares just saying have a pawn i need
to win i'm going to take some risks and
uh i think this move at least blocks the
queens so we won't see a queen exchange
which uh i think liam lee has to go for
he has to keep the queens on the board
he needs to win this game if he doesn't
win this game it's going to be really
really tough so uh an interesting move
there yeah and uh the main reason you
mentioned that the knight has joined uh
has kind of parked itself in front of
the white queen in front of the white
bishop is because if black just develops
a very normal move free standard move
than this pawn sacrifice
we would see fireworks if this happened
simon uh black winning a pawn in the
center but white gaining space gaining
time now against the black knight and
this pawn on this square the e5 square
often acts as a launch pad for white's
attack later the white pieces could use
central squares now to go for the black
king if it goes to the side of the wood
and i just had it confirmed it was uh my
spider senses were tingling and i was
like i know this position
and it's because it's part of sam
shanklin's chassis ball course okay so i
was like
haven't i've been doing the moo training
practice exactly
and uh
yeah i was like unusual it was an
unusual choice it's not mainstream this
yeah that's very interesting because sam
is uh really famous for his theoretical
knowledge and obviously his chesapeal
course is one of the highest highest
rated courses out there does magnus
notice corso because he's thinking about
it i mean he he should know it um but
it's uh yeah what a what an interesting
move yeah he should know but i doubt
magnus does uh magnus of course watches
a lot of chessable stuff himself um he's
very very knowledgeable about all sorts
of openings and also he used to work
with sam shanklin remember sam helped
him in the 2016 world championship match
but then again this is quite a rare move
and it's not magnus's main opening from
the black pieces magnus has been playing
a few different things lately
both against one e4 and one d4 and this
is not magnus's main line so against a
very rare sideline like this
i wouldn't be surprised if he's
surprised and uh liam meanwhile
fighting chess and look at that stance
kind of crossing his arms just looking
like a boss there
i like this last move and uh
yeah also liam now living in the u.s uh
coaching the us uh he will be very aware
of ideas from players such as uh sam
shankland okay well game two for cameron
nepomniacci has also started they played
a draw in the first game our tamiya ding
game two has started ding one the first
game is up by one point hansen and
asepanko game two will start shortly
that was looking good for esipenko the
entire game but it ended in a draw so
hunson must have played some fantastic
defensive moves there to save that draw
and he will have the white pieces in the
upcoming game bunch of moves wow yeah a
bunch of moves and maybe i was wrong
maybe magnus wasn't surprised he took a
while but he did eventually come up with
a flurry of quick moves and we saw a
trade of a set of pawns in the centre of
the board black's dark square bishop
came out and actually traded itself off
for a night but look at the pawn
structure now in the middle of the board
white has an isolated pawn we call it an
iqp an isolated queen's pawn and it can
be very strong it controls lots of
squares but it can also be a weakness
long term and actually it can even be
captured right now by the black queen
black's queen can come down and take a
pawn but that would lose a lot of time
the black queen will get kicked around
the board and the fact that liam's
played so quickly up to this point means
he's for sure still in his homework
um i would be too scared to capture that
pawn and i must admit i would try and
get black's pieces out as quickly as
possible look at them they're all still
asleep they need to develop there's a
nasty trick if black does capture the
pawn here uh i assume white can start
swinging uh i'm using that term swinging
again
don't know why don't ask me
swinging it into action and he can bring
it to uh this this square next to the
queen maybe c4 i'm thinking and this has
a really nasty little fret so let's say
black pushes or tries to push that
knight away by using the b pawn well
hang on a minute there's a there's a
common idea here black now loses his
queen to a nasty discovered check this
is a another little tactic we talked
about pins earlier this is a discovery
you can also call it an ambush you
ambush the queen and you win the queen
there so i wouldn't be touching that
pawn there if i was magnus and magnus
this is just the position you want
against magnus because again it was
mentioned when the queens are off magnus
is phenomenal the way you beat him you
keep the queens on you get the
initiative you go for the attack it's
the only chance really i think of taking
him down and uh liam blacquan's got the
position he he would dream of before
before this game started so uh great
opening choice definitely yeah fully
agreed
yeah this position is full of life and
that's exactly what liam needs in order
to fight back and if there's one like
tiny weakness that we've seen in
magnus's armor it's that
at times he can be a little bit
negligent about king safety you know
we've we've seen him get checkmated
and especially i'm thinking back to the
2021 season and well we're quite happy
here because magnus decided not to take
that uh
we thought poison porn
yeah if we rewind 14 months to the air
things masters on last season against
daniel dubois he got checkmated i think
it was three times in their mini match
over the two days um he's been
checkmated a few times by wesley so
yeah it's all about king safety and if
you look at white's bishops here they
both point in the general direction of
the black king so the
kind of outline of an attack exists but
magnus will be hoping that he can get
organized before that attack really
starts to take shape
this last bishop move i kind of like it
but i
do just i don't know something
instinctively it feels a bit slow
i mean what about this knight trying to
move into that juicy square
in the center of the board i mean with
tempo
that's the first move that springs to
mind get the knight active use that
activity and you know when you have the
initiative as white has a slight
initiative here you you've got to play
as actively as you can and bring the
knight in start creating some frets
start uh probing uh black's king side
here and i you know i don't think magnus
will be comfortable in this position
yeah i guess his idea is to plant his
bishop on the long diagonal and just
hope that he'll get some counter play
later on this diagonal against the white
king yes the white knight can jump in
protected by this bishop to attack a
rook but after the rook moves
maybe there's no follow through it looks
beautiful for white especially this
knight is going to be a real thorn in
black side but
maybe there's no follow-up immediately
so
yeah i mean plenty of options in the
current position as well i mean this
looks so tempting simon actually he does
play it i was going to say there are
options of maybe bringing the white
queen across trying to swing it towards
the black king but first he brings his
knight in and the bishop does indeed
park itself on this square
it looks so scary for black yeah this
bishop's just cutting the board in half
in a way yeah maybe the knight can also
just come into the center exactly uh
just to
have start looking at some of those
squares around the black king i'm not so
keen on this one though black can now
threaten checkmate
hit this
[Laughter]
bishops but that's not so great here so
yeah i don't think white wants to spend
so many moves with this knight over the
last few turns just to capture this
bishop and allow black's knights out
suddenly black is very active and this
pawn very very weak so okay instead
white just brings his rook to the side
okay he i guess wants to meet this queen
move by just stepping back with his
knight attacking the queen and also
defending this key pawn in front of the
white king but
maybe not the most energetic move this
last one by white just bringing across
maybe there was something even better
i'm not sure
and uh okay magnus still under some
pressure though
in order to
fight back in this game and especially
this black knight needs to get out at
some point and we can remember liam
lacroix was actually uh blitz world
champion um so he he's uh as well as you
know um being a class player he he's
very good at blitz he's not you know not
a spectator in this competition um
but i don't know you this last move as
you mentioned what's it actually doing
and you've got to always play with a
purpose i mean it's an obvious move you
move the rook to a half open file but
does it actually threaten anything i
can't see a threat here i mean
maybe he wants to lift that rook off the
board and swing it across yes
he's getting the swing of it
[Laughter]
yeah
and
yeah i mean it's it's as you say simon
sometimes in rapid chess especially you
just find the hand playing automatic
moves which just look good which
slightly improve your position but don't
actually have a purpose or a plan
necessarily this feels like that type of
move but then again
if magnus isn't able to get active
himself then white will have for sure
ideas with this white rook so yeah it
feels like the next three or four moves
are going to be really critical yeah i
agree with you david i mean one thing
that i have i do have some experience
playing against this pawn this isolated
queen's porn as we call it and one of
the things i found is that you have to
tread very carefully you have to use a
lot of energy just neutralizing white
dynamism with the pieces and once you've
done that then you can kind of maybe
enjoy the fruits of your labor
around about move 40 or something when
you've gone into an end game but for
rapid chess this is like the perfect
opening for white you have to get to
move 40 and
again it's one of those typical
structures where if you're if you're
playing chess we talked about this
earlier you might know the opening but
you should always be thinking what kind
of middle game position do i like
playing and famously like karpov uh used
to like playing the black side of these
positions he used to like playing
against the isolated pawn but then there
are other players and i expect casper
off like playing with the isolated pawn
so it does come down to personal choice
uh quite a lot and what suits your style
of play
and you've got to bear that in mind when
you're picking openings i think you've
got to pick openings which you enjoy
playing there's no point playing a
position where you might be better but
you're not really enjoying it you don't
really want to you know find the best
moves because you won't find the best
moves so uh but this this suits
certainly uh liam lee kuang's style of
play so
you mentioned that simon actually when i
was young all of my openings were geared
towards this exact pawn structure with
white i always wanted the isolated pawn
if i know i've lost so many times to you
i know i know you've always got these
positions against me and uh i'm sure and
i always struggled so
i was about to say though the older i
get the more i want to be on the black
side against the isolated pawn because
white's position takes energy and i
don't have the energy these days
when i was young i would use the
isolated when you were young hang on a
minute when i was younger hang in a
minute
sorry how old are you david
i can't even remember 29. i'm 29. i wish
31.
you're still you're still a spring
chicken
definitely okay when i was a teenager
when i was still kind of learning my
steps in the game i would always use
this spawn structure as an attack as a
way to attack the black king but then
these days i believe more in defense and
i just love just locking things down as
magnus is trying to do planting the
bishop in front of the isolated pawn
just hoping that there won't be an
attack and then long term uh trying to
utilize the superior structure the pawn
structure that black has it's a very
strange idea here you can move that
knight into the center and do the same
rook move you played can that knight
jump towards the king i mean that that's
the kind of uh you look at the black
king you're trying to attack it let's
move our pieces uh towards that king
very brutal uh chest so maybe we can
just show that then the knight attacks
the rook if the rook just slips up um
and comes forwards then maybe the knight
moves again i i don't know if this
achieves anything it might not but um
you're getting nearer that king are
there any frets here you probably as
white need to get your queen into this
position if your queen could fly out
this could be terminal but maybe black's
okay here and the trick is that if the
knight gets captured then the bishop can
now pounce and capture the black rook
and yes you've given up a knight as
white but now your bishop is protected
by your own brook
so very very sneaky tactic as you
mentioned simon the key question would
be whether white has a follow through if
the black rook just moves again and
retreats does white knight also has to
have to take a step back
i mean it would be very tempting to look
at sacrifices here knight takes pawn
opening up the black king then trying to
get the white queen in uh for example
visit towards the black king but
maybe it's not quite enough you only
have a couple of attackers and black
does have a very strong defender in this
night this is the kind of sacrifice i
would do then i'd probably resign three
moves later
this is the kind of move you think later
yeah wow very optimistic sacrifice and
uh you know as as you get older you
realize you have to have more pieces in
the attack before these things work um
but it's an idea that obviously is
hanging uh in the position if if white
can get another piece and maybe with
your idea of anchor of bringing the rook
in possibly bring the rook in step the
queen up onto the dark squares i mean
there's i think you've got to build it
you can't get too enthusiastic at the
beginning and talking about enjoyment
simon i'm sure you'll appreciate this
tweet from valentino who says
it's a little known fact chess and
fishing was written prior to 1897.
before the blitz and bullets existed as
there was much more time between moves
to deal with a live fish on the line
i thought you were being serious
really i've been
it seems like it goes perfectly a bit of
fishing get the chess board out exactly
chill out exactly well especially
nowadays with your phone you can have
like a chess app yeah fishing yeah and
there's a reason why yeah that's a good
idea the the top engines are like stock
fish yeah and everything
little fish yeah you know
there's like history there and we also
have an interesting question from
charlie hill who asks us magnus is such
a strong player but following his defeat
against pragananda do you think his
opponents will have more confidence in
being able to push for a win against
magnus
i'm i mean i i i guess whenever you're
playing magnus no matter if he's lost
the game he's the world champion you're
gonna have a little bit of fear uh
because he's the best player in the
world um
it might give them more confidence it
should it should certainly give prague
more confidence as he said in the
interview that he you know once you've
beaten someone once uh you feel a lot
better when you play them again i mean
again i haven't overcome that with david
but uh in the past i remember other
rivals of mine i'd have a terrible score
and you get one win against them and
your confidence builds you play better
and then it works out you can you can
win a a lot of games in a row after that
so it is a confidence thing chess uh
often you know just having that
confidence to
believe in yourself yeah mental game
right so yeah on that subject for a long
time i was simon's past what we call
customer you know he would he would just
play anything it would just beat me
and then one time i beat him
i can't remember that
it might have happened i don't know
doubtful and then after that you know i
was like you struggled a little bit
against me last time we played you you
crushed me on about move 20 and my king
ended up
oh it's painful
you know so yeah yeah that wasn't the
last time was it oh no no the last time
i think worse well i managed to draw but
i was i was let's say
winning quite quite quite well so yeah
thank you for bringing about those
memories you've anchor just uh yeah well
what does simon and pregnant have in
common
oh dear um
both yeah both speed magnets during the
year thanks monsters okay
all right well
no fish here it's just two sharks
playing the game and fighting it out
there have been a few moves uh in the
meantime white knight has gone on an
adventure but not towards the black king
white's knight has gone off to the queen
side instead it was attacking a black
rook but meanwhile white has centralized
a rook black's queen not entirely safe
on the square she stands on eyed up
indirectly by white's rook on the bottom
of the board there check out that
tension later between the white rook and
the black queen meanwhile liam just
taking a timeout we've seen this time
and time again
by the top players when in doubt just
push a pawn normally this pawn in front
of your king to give it some breathing
space and
it's really tense in the middle of the
board actually right now i don't see how
black breaks that tension though white's
dark squared bishop and that white
knight cemented on nice squares the
question is for both sides what next and
uh black needs to improve as rooks white
needs to maybe get the queen into the
action
and yes the evaluation bar's gone down
it used to be loving white's position
but still a lot of problems for black to
solve and game two between camera and
napogniachi has ended in a draw so they
are still tied both games
and then ending up in draws game three
will start in about 10 minutes i think a
quick draw this game too between these
two
all right another move another movement
black does deal with the first issue i
mentioned that the black rooks need to
improve the problem is both black brooks
kind of want to use this one square
and black now has one decent rook
and look how it's opposite the white
queen
again just a general pattern to remember
planting your rook opposite the enemy
queen can be a nice way to annoy your
opponent
could black i know it's a bit about
outrageous idea here because the one
advantage black has is you know in
isolated pawn positions black has a
better pawn structure because the white
pawn can be weak in the ending and black
would love to swap off loads of pieces
and start hitting that white pawn in the
middle of the ball because none of
black's pawns are weak
but could black be trying to play
his pawn to e5 pushing that forwards
maybe okay to open up a rook towards the
white queen i mean uh i i it looks like
the wrong thing to do but
if you're really desperate to get some
activity it's it's maybe an idea yeah
it's maybe even more tempting now that
white's queen is still on a square
opposite one of the black rooks and uh
pushing this pawn forward as you say it
does allow white to trade off one of his
long-term weaknesses but if you take now
then it gets really messy
black actually has a choice you can take
with the black rook and hit the white
queen afterwards or you can take with a
black knight and uh i mean who's queen
is under more threat here i don't know
uh the black rook trying to get
through to the white queen whereas the
white rook trying to break through to
the black queen there are pieces in the
way
both sides could throw pieces out of the
way now to try and create those attacks
but yeah just one big mess personally i
would be reluctant unless magnus is 100
sure that this gives him something
immediately
but then again maybe it does so
really interesting move here by simon as
you say counterintuitive maybe or going
against the rules but black's pieces
then again they are nicely centralized
the black knights on their perfect
squares the blacks
black rooks also on their perfect
squares so maybe now it's the moment
rather than sit passively
uh to break out in the center and push
the pawn i don't see any downsides to it
yet yeah i remember one thing you said
yesterday about the way magnus plays and
he doesn't like playing these moves
really i mean he prefers to keep it
positionally sound um and only play a
move like that if it really does work
and he hasn't played it here
he's he's got a great deal of patience
and i suppose he's just trying to
activate his queen now on the king's
side um makes makes a lot of sense as
well yeah partly attacking this pawn
with the knight now and the queen but
also maybe as you mentioned going
towards the white king
and uh
okay that does make liam a bit
uncomfortable and a queen trade is
happening who's got the best uh end game
technique we're gonna find out because
after queen takes queen white now does
have the opportunity of playing pawn
takes and
okay he takes with the rook instead i
was gonna say teaming up with his pawns
no more isolated pawns these pawns are
connected but then again black could
maybe blockade in the center of the
board and try and trade some pieces so
rook takes i must admit i'm surprised by
that one though i'm really surprised by
that one because my understanding of all
this is that if white were to get two
connected past
two connected pawns then they would be
slightly better so i've always avoided
trading any pieces on that particular e3
square yeah you you always want to
improve your pawn structure if you can i
mean that's just
something you do especially as you're
getting nearer the ending where the
queens come off and taking with the pawn
would have improved white's pawn
structure because the isolated pawn is
not an isolated pawn so he's sacrificing
that for peace activity um he's still
got two bishops so should be okay here
for white but the queen exchange must
help magnus yeah i'm surprised the
evaluation bar's still on white side
actually because now after this night
retreat um again just allowing some
trades this doesn't really favor white
in any way it does feel like black is
the one who has specific ideas in mind
maybe the black bishop would just drop
back and then a knight could occupy this
square that's the normal rule uh if your
opponent has an isolated pawn like this
the best blockaders are knights black
bishop looks good but if you can replace
it with a knight that's even better
also the black knight can jump out this
way attack the white rook plenty of
ideas here i think white is the one who
needs to be energetic and accurate and i
don't really see the plan to be honest
black's bishop just defends everything
and if you ever trade it off it does
indeed get replaced by one of the black
knights and normally bishops are better
normally you prefer having two bishops
rather than two nights but here the
bishops don't really have any targets
blacks knights are the ones which won't
be dislodged from these fantastic
central squares i do have one vague idea
and it's just based on the whole concept
that when you do have this isolated pawn
in the middle of the board um your
position tends to be okay in an end game
if you control the open line so in this
case it would be the sea like the sea
lion
and so i'm thinking well my knight the
white knight is like perfectly placed
for that so maybe try to initiate some
trades to stop the bishop going back but
or
um well so for example taking this
knight yeah maybe yeah could never
challenge for this file yeah possibly um
but then i guess it's hard to do
anything with this file and yeah yeah i
mean i i like your idea i probably would
have been tempted to take as well but uh
instead liam showing patience himself
this time and just dropping back with
his rook so maybe he still has this idea
in mind to take this knight and then he
wants to lift this rook up the board not
to swing it across this time but just to
double up his rooks on the only open
file the c file and okay very very tense
but we're in the end game now
and
it's all about technique all about
general understanding the magnus is up
by one point there is a new format this
season so quartz final matches and
semi-final matches are decided on one
day last year it was two days to decide
the matches but this year only one day
to decide the quarterfinal matches and
what magnus talked about it in the
interview yesterday he thinks that
favors him a little bit right because he
did struggle
in quite a lot of the on the day two
matches basically yeah it's strange
because normally magnus at least
historically is a slow starter
but i guess just having this one day
these four games to throw every ounce of
energy into it's just easier for him
maybe especially after suffering with
kovid uh maybe just the remaining energy
he has or as he builds up his strength
again um just throwing his energy in
it's more of a sprint now than a long
distance run at least and
maybe yeah that will suit him yeah so
that does mean everyone that
if uh matches are tied after four games
then we do head straight to tie breaks
and odds are definitely that we will
have some blitz chess today because
well
yeah kymer and the pognyarchy they are
tied after two games
and uh
uh hansen and nezipanko they are they
drew the first game and let's see what
happens in game two between those two
well in this one the bar is always sort
of slightly liking liam's situation a
little bit better yeah um again i'm
surprised it is because i think magnus
is just playing very very solid moves
and now um ivanka mentioned this white
knight just stopping black accessing the
c file with the black rooks
with a potential nitrate blacks rooks
would get access to that file yeah one
thing i've noticed with computers i mean
i i don't always trust their judgment
and
in isolated porn positions they always
like having the isolated porn i don't
think they often realize the long-term
problems that that for example white has
with this pawn magnus is doing
everything right the more exchanges the
weaker that pawn becomes and
i i think it's going magnus's way
because he's exchanging yes white has
two bishops yes white is is not worse
but i think magnus is now comfortable at
least here um with a nice hold in the
center of the board and again going back
to boris baskey he mentioned that it
wasn't the isolated pawn which is the
weakness it's the square in front of the
isolated pawn which is actually the real
weakness and you can see the only the
bishop black's bishop in the middle of
the board it can't be kicked away uh by
a pawn even though it's just moved so uh
so black certainly has control of some
nice squares uh in the middle here yeah
actually you're completely right i've
analyzed so many isolated queens pawn
positions with computers and they always
overestimate white's chances often they
say white has a plus one advantage but
then they just want to move their rook
back and forth back and forth and do
nothing also the computers do slightly
overestimate the bishop pair sometimes
as well
i think some computers are even
programmed to say bishops when they're
as a pair are worth 3.5 or 3.25 each
whereas a knight is worth three and uh
small adjustments like that might
explain why the evaluation bar prefers
white but look at the black knight now
it's never getting kicked away
this position very very healthy for
black and as you say simon white's not
worse but he's definitely not better
anymore either no no i mean it's uh
it's maybe equal but i i mean
i'm just thinking why if i was white
here i'd be trying to look at my pawns
now because black's got such good
control and i'd be trying to push my
king side pawns
but
black is so solid now
in the center and i i just think magnus
is fine here at the moment at least i
think
liam is probably just
playing to
for draw
i think he's quite happy with that
yeah i don't think there's many winning
chances left if magnus had actually
left that knight in the center of the
board liam would have captured it and
the game would have fizzled out we saw
opposite color bishops in vincent kaima
against jannaponnichi that ended in a
draw and if the bishop the white light
squad bishop had traded off for a night
we would have seen opposite colour
bishops again that's why magnus
retreated his knight maybe he senses
some small chances of winning this game
is black
that's the only reason i can uh justify
that knight retreat but i was yeah i was
about to say white can continue chasing
that knight and now bishop takes knight
or the bishop going back where it came
from both of those moves are going to
lead to a draw this game is fizzling out
wow yeah good news for magnus then he
will have the right pieces in game three
and basically if he wins that game he's
going to already be ready for the
semi-finals liam he uh needs to win a
game here to take it tie breaks and
after this one only two more rapid games
to go
uh opposite color bishop simon
pawn structure basically symmetrical
could it get any more drawish no i don't
think so i mean like you know they're
playing these brilliant moves on the
side now but it doesn't make any
difference pushing harry here um but
it's it's a dead draw um and
you know unless you make a big blunder
here you know they're they're shake
hands or or click mouses very soon
click mouses i like that yeah what was
it that jana pogbachie tweeted on the
first day warriors of the mouse warriors
assembled
i like that one yeah yeah okay and and
now magnus is really just offering that
handshake and now the rooks are going to
come off and that's just going to be a
case of uh those opposite colored
bishops just like someone getting
divorced yeah that's right yeah they're
kids passing in the night ships passing
tonight i like that yeah yeah they can
never connect oh you know
we're gonna have another poem come in
and buy someone so you're not with that
yeah there you go someone write a poem
about the opposite color bishops yeah we
do love that or a selfie with a
picture of opposite color bishops do
that and we'll feature that on the show
yeah or with your divorce wife if you
want to
if you can arrange that
[Laughter]
asking for trouble but meanwhile we're
about to see the draw agreed nothing to
be done it's a blockade for both sides
and there we go the position repeats
itself it's a draw all right magnus
still up by one point after two games
here in
this quarter-final match